je suis le monde mais quand même vous
êtes connaisseurs joker c'est parti
virginie guînes et leur vice-président
les républicains et député de haute
savoie
j'adore danse avec les stars c'est
l'émission que je regarde souvent avec
ma fille aya nakamura
[Musique]
plutôt annemasse évidemment une belle
commune de ma circonscription
[Musique]
plus tôt lyon c'est ma région auvergne
rhône-alpes donc forcément un
attachement de coeur est un connaisseur
plutôt roblochon plutôt coup de coeur je
suis plutôt quelqu'un d'optimiste en
général une station de ski évidemment je
suis élu dans une belle région des alpes
donc forcément on se bat pour défendre
l'économie du tourisme ski de piste mais
ski de fond depuis moins longtemps et
fort c'est évidemment par la fermeture
des remontées mécaniques
c'est un choix s'il met plutôt raclette
et évidemment on a des bons fromages sur
mon pays de savoie francis cabrel est
pensé pour la dernier ôte sa voix salle
de sport je suis une adepte du sport du
tout on skie fils course à pied et les
salles de sport et on espère leur
réouverture parce qu'elles souffrent
beaucoup en ce moment
plutôt sms est assez pratique et puis ça
permet d'être réactif
plutôt centre pompidou viennent beaucoup
l'art contemporain
[Musique]